er liegt als allererstes die frage zu
unserer aktuellste nachricht die
sperrstunde hier in berlin wurde soeben
gekippt was halten sie davon
ich finde das ehrlich gesagt ein
rückstand ein rückschlag für unsere
fahne wie bekämpfung wir wissen dass
gerade aus der kneipen gastro szene aus
der partyszene unheimlich viele
infektionen auch in neukölln aber auch
den innenstadtbezirken von ausgegangen
sind und von daher haben wir jetzt
natürlich das problem dass wieder mehr
menschen dann auch unterwegs sind in
kneipen um zu feiern zu singen zu tanzen
ähnlich ist und genau das wird auch zu
infektionsgeschehen die wir versuchen zu
bekämpfen die begründung ist jedoch dass
dieses verbot unverhältnismäßig ist im
vergleich zu anderen maßnahmen und man
hat auch folgen darüber diskutiert sind
nicht bars kneipen restaurants genau die
orte wo man es wenn überhaupt noch
nachvollziehen kann weil man muss ja
davon ausgehen wenn man dort nicht mehr
hingehen darf treffen sich die leute im
privat- und dann wird es noch
schwieriger solche kontakt hätten dann
im nachhinein noch zu entdecken
also wir hatten schon in den vergangen
in der vergangenheit große probleme
überhaupt infektionsgeschehen auch in
solchen restaurants bars kneipen
nachzuvollziehen weil angaben
unvollständig waren die listen nicht
ordentlich geführt wurden und so weiter
ich habe da meine erheblichen zweifel
dran natürlich geht auch aus dem
privatbereich sehr viel an infektionen
aus das wissen wir von hochzeit und
familienveranstaltungen und ähnliches
dass das stimmt aber ich hatte ehrlich
gesagt den gesundheitsschutz für
höherwertige als die möglichkeit wir
trinken zu gehen denn der kleine aber
das gericht hat so entschieden und ich
gehe davon aus dass der berliner senat
dagegen beschwerde einlegen wird
jetzt wollen wir noch etwas mehr über
neukölln sprechen denn die zahlen dort
sind noch viel höher als ansonsten in
berlin vor allem im vergleich zu
deutschland haben sie eine erklärung
dafür wie das passieren konnte
im privaten bereich und aus der
partyszene heraus entstanden inzwischen
ist aber soweit in die bevölkerung
eingesickert das virus deswegen
überhaupt keine konkrete lokalisierung
mehr vornehmen können
das betrifft übrigens nicht nur neukölln
sondern sämtliche ebenen stadtbereiche
und dass wir so eine hohe intelligenz
haben es mehr als erschreckend das ist
ja auch ein entsprechendes eine
entsprechende sperrstunde verhängt
worden
wir müssen jetzt überlegen wie wir
weitere maßnahmen treffen denn unser
hauptziel ist es im iran und gruppen
also menschen mit besonderer gefährdung
zu schützen und da werden wir den
absoluten schwerpunkt auflegen
jetzt wollen sich natürlich besonders
viele menschen testen lassen denn die
angst ist da dass man sich doch
angesteckt hat wenn man in diesen
bereichen wohnt wie läuft es momentan
mit der testung wie schnee kommen sie
überhaupt noch hinterher und brauchen
sie unterstützung von außerhalb um
überhaupt noch her über diese lage zu
werden
massiv dabei personal aufzustocken was
die vermittlung angeht und auch die
kontakt nachverfolgung und in der
konsequenz auch die quarantäne sierung
wir haben einen corona ab sprich zentrum
in neukölln was gut ausgelastet ist aber
noch luft nach oben hat viel mehr sorgen
macht mir die laborkapazitäten die bei
über 95 prozent auslastung sind als die
testungen müssen dann in einem labor
ausgewertet werden das kann schon mal
bis zu vier tagen dauern
gegebenenfalls sogar länger und so lange
sind die menschen ja noch eigentlich
unterwegs und das ist eben auch die
große gefahr dass sich das virus weiter
ausbreitet für frage was fordern sie
jetzt von den bürgern damit die
situation endlich wieder besser wird die
gesamtverantwortung nicht alleine beim
gesundheitsamt abladen da muss jeder
jetzt zu beitragen das heißt party ist
aber jeder muss sich genau überlegen mit
wem er in welcher anzahl sich trifft und
sich verabredet oder feierlichkeiten
begeht wir müssen jetzt alle sehr sehr
eng zusammenhalten um menschen zu
schützen die besonders gefährdet sind
ganz haben wir einen deutlichen anstieg
von todesfällen das wollen wir natürlich
verhindern also jeder einzelne ist
gefragt oder dass es auch mein appell an
die menschen seien sie vernünftig halten
sie die hygieneregeln ein und machen sie
keine party wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren